another thing I want to ask you there
are things about me that you don't like
cuz you brought it up in the last year
coming up I do there are so let's just
get you know what I think this is a good
time period right price in there for
what do you hide God there was a [ __ ]
TV back arts he's like yeah you sleep
alright I think this is a good time baby
get it out you get it off our chest why
not go ahead okay what is it I do hope
you're all first of all you don't first
there's a few things you don't text back
that's not okay dude look at him
everyone here is not and I know what
text back way text back right text back
okay go ahead what are you gonna do with
this by the way when you order I need I
have a rebuttals okay you don't text
back okay when we go to a diner yeah you
just eat and then you're done and you
leave and I don't like okay it's for
hanging out and I'm go to a diner to eat
and that's not cool you go to a diner to
hang out with your friends number one
number number number three is [ __ ] what
was the other one what what is it that
when I see you in public I get the
Comedy Store so I don't get into
conversation yeah I know it yeah it's
fine that we don't get into a
conversation but you just you just you
don't sometimes you just walk by yeah
and you say hey to like some other
clever like Emmett Christie or whoever
put your friends with and I love Kevin
then you won't say hi to me okay good
don't say hi yeah well you think it up
in a second oh you you you when we're at
a diner sometimes you'll you'll be like
and you'll start playing your games and
and
Oh games okay those are good for their
very good thing very good Chris
[ __ ] rebuttal oh that's very I love you
the do were talking about
Sudi I love you but let me just can I
please thank you okay all right text
back number one okay
communication with your phone right for
me is a lifeline to the world just
listen to what I'm saying I know you're
doing your eyes on their baggie right
now okay so it's I your taxes are like
this bra bra I'm not even kidding
they're kind of like that spell
something yeah I do what G dealing yeah
right yeah yeah oh that's [ __ ] you do
right so I'm 45 I'll be honest with you
and I'm in the car I get a text from
Chris bra bra right
I end minutes no I so I just kind of let
it go yeah so if you were to do
something like hey dude I went to the
hospital and I got some bad news right
let me tell you something right now no
no Lisa fake crying okay I'd be the
first one to text you back I know dude
well let me ask you a question yeah why
why what why would you be the first one
because I love you so much I think what
it is yeah you secretly want to get in
good with God I think you want yes
points with whoever you use this [ __ ]
made me so angry right now made me so
[ __ ] angry then I am NOT even gonna
[ __ ] address it right now okay all
right yeah the second one is this I eat
and I'm done
okay let me tell you something right now
friend all right all right bro you're I
don't you're pointing at me let me tell
you something about you right now right
okay all right let me say something all
right to survive in life you need
several things you need action yeah
right you need h2o where's that water
water
you need sleep shelter right and [ __ ]
food right so what I'm saying to you
right now is is that like if you and I
were like camping we're sleeping yeah
and when I'm done sleeping yeah I'm not
gonna just lay next to you all right
in the tent and just watch you [ __ ]
sleep right I'm gonna go out chop some
wood for us so we get some fire right
I'm gonna get the bow and arrows ready
so I'm gonna get bow and arrows ready
for us for the great hunt right yeah
sure right and then like an hour later
you wake up and I already have coffee
ready for you dude yeah but I guess what
I'm saying is is that that's what eating
to me is eating is once I'm done eating
I'm off he doesn't know how to just hang
out I know it's a big that's the bigger
thing last week we went to shabu shabu
it and you sit on those large it's
almost like a communal kind of area and
it's just him and I right halfway
through the meal I'm not done yet he's
out smoking a cigarette and then he pays
and I'm still eating there for the last
20 minutes by myself it's just not you
it's everybody no no I'm still I know
it's not just me but so what so then
what do you do when he's out there in
the beginning you used to really
preserve me I would have man used to
make oh my god it used to really bother
me and at some point I realized it was
probably just as a DD taking over it is
and it wasn't anything I could take
personally I need help so I did that I
won the text Bobbie will head Chris y/10
Bobby you want to eat I'm done I won
that with camping analogy right yeah
don't say hi okay I got a great thing
for okay this is it all right so you
know usually you and I will see each
other primarily in a social setting like
a comedy club right okay so here's a guy
right he's a good-looking male you know
alpha male
stand-up who's successful did two shows
back to back on a network right he's you
know he's like I'm you know he's the
light and that there's mobs around him
Oh yummy huh okay all right so I pull up
right
I got nothing Mike my light is dim
that's stupid I know around an hour oh
yeah let me talk all right ever wants to
walk it like one MA yeah yeah then I see
a brighter light right then I go no more
[ __ ] mouth bro right I'm a light too
right do you hear what I'm saying so
it's like when a dimmer light goes into
a brighter light when he has all those
mouths
sometimes the dimmer light will just
walk on by yeah and doesn't say hello
all right cuz they're lice yeah what cuz
their lights
no he's just saying you shut the [ __ ] up
right now I love you but yeah that's why
I understand but but you're but you're
you're you're bigger than that you know
what I mean
no yeah you are because you'll say hi
you'll say hi to other people
right and then you won't say hi to me
you say hi to the matching lights people
who are in the same baby Tim I couldn't
set a better but yeah but that's the
thing though that's the [ __ ] 25
percent disrespect is what I'm talking
about
who think I need that you think I need
someone you think you walk on by yeah I
don't need that [ __ ] will you need more
moths no yeah no you you are who you are
in your head bro not on the outside man
I am Who I am in my head do it when you
walk by you don't say [ __ ]
yeah I'm inside my head bro yeah how do
you think I get Facebook guys right now
right now that one a draw you know what
it's a draw it's only to zero okay that
was a good point
all right all right you two one
he wanted that one all right I'll give
you one
with you wander the ATD you maybe won
the camping analogy one but not the
texting one dude alright I think it's hi
it's 2 2 1 1
I'll keep it won't walk alright games ok
o games 1 we're eating yeah okay here's
the thing deal alright yeah when you're
at a diner with this [ __ ] guy you
usually go out with what you Fahim yes
maybe some other people you know will
sasso
right right sure you have all these
funny guys right at a table right and
what happens with these guys that they
riff yeah and they they try to outdo
each other and they try to build this
like fun cake build a fun cake
right big one right and you know what I
do I'm done I'm done baking fun cakes
yeah you don't really I'm thinking about
it right now yeah yeah I actually am and
that's really interesting yeah cuz
you're the kind of guy you got all the
things you got all the [ __ ] tools to
build the fun cake yeah you know you I
have all the ingredients you know I have
the apron I have the oven I have all the
ingredients I know you have it all right
you know what you are you're the red
belt on [ __ ] fun cake you got you're
the you're the black belt with all the
red stripes tied all around yeah cuz
you're [ __ ] first down second down
third all the done and the whole belt is
covered in red yeah you just sit back
and you watch everyone else fight that's
what you do yeah I know and you know
what what why is that a bad thing
because sometimes yeah we want the
sensei or the red belt to just kind of
assimilate with us and I think I won
that you 1 K 2 1 you definitely won that
one ok ok well that's it though but I
gave you a really big compliment the end
I think that's why you let me win that
you're saying okay you won that one yeah
called a red belt at the end of the day
what the truth is this is that I know I
won 3-0 that's the truth
okay and I'm just letting you have it
you like guests let me tell you
something well I haven't been in a room
this small with this many people
since I was in high school yeah there's
so many [ __ ] people I hope that in
the cameras don't see I know right yeah
and I'm sorry but you know when we as
this thing grows yeah you know that we
get guests like yourself and it's gonna
get bigger and then we'll have to we'll
be forced to move okay well I hope I can
help that you know them you're gonna
help that and and we want to help you
because you have a podcast I do thank
you yeah yeah I have yeah yeah gets
called congratulations I want to plug
that all right so it's called
congratulations yes with crystal yay
[Music]